I'm clearly not of that generation so I
really wouldn't know I mean it's just
this is how people glue themselves
together now the world is ludicrously
fast and this is one way of letting
everybody know so unsurprisingly the
next generation utilize it as a means of
like you know and then it's perceived by
lots of older middle-aged middle-class
journalists as being like cool and
somehow exciting so everyone's desperate
for something new to write about so it
gains attention when really is pretty
unremarkable isn't it people just put
words down or send a photo in or
something I I don't even know how all
these things work does the idea of
communicating more than I currently do
is just not really on my radar I'm
looking for a world where there's less
communication
I'm just not sure how far the
empowerment goes it's still about
attracting attention albeit in a
different way and those people with the
greatest influence will get the most
attention and the odd story will crop up
which will sort of there's a the new
thing you know something new that no
one's heard of before that they pass
around like really fast that's what
happened with white ladder it was
something new and it got passed about
that's that you see that will happen to
the odd thing but I don't see us a
radical new way of selling music that
that favors the smaller producer kind of
thing it just you know people like
iTunes are desperately trying to keep
their page so free from like being just
bought out period by every all the
interested parties so things take place
in a slightly more sort of convoluted
way you give them loads of stuff
now it's an errors of your time and
they'll semi guarantee that you'll get
some good coverage or something on there
their front page yeah that's how it
works sort of thing it's like it's sort
of gifting rather than just naked
financial ruthless power seizing their
front page hears loads of money we want
this artist on the front for a month
because so everyone will know every time
they click on bang oh they got you
record it so I but this stuff will
eventually prevail I dare say
to say I'm not a fan of the music
industry it's like I've spent enough
money with it and enough time
persevering with it it's it's obviously
been it's been born of it it was very
greedy and it's basically a history of
ripping people off it's how it made so
much money and then they defend up the
CD and went hey this is good we can sell
all the same music again in a different
format and they thought this is the
future and at that point they dropped
the ball completely and utterly they
started to give things away on
promotional sort of and the gross of
incompetence of the whole thing is
laughable really this is a very cold
it's a cold-hearted digital world that
doesn't seem to care much for music or
sort of nurturing it because there's
infinitesimal reward for zillions of
hits on YouTube or whatever so it just
doesn't work as a formula music doesn't
come for free strangely enough people
spend hundreds of thousands of pounds
and many years producing things it's
like that's why it sounds good